how are you guys doing
I'm quickly going to do a review and
this is not really a planned review I
just watched this um
it was for me quite interesting and it
was a kind of call it cross-examination
from Piers Morgan and Andrew Tate and in
this uh
cross-examination I would say that Piers
Morgan really made a fool of himself
incessant Interruption uh embarrassing
insecurities on display I mean I
couldn't even hear the answers that
Andrew Tate was giving because Piers
Morgan was just so persistent
um persistent in his uh Interruption I I
have no idea how someone that is
involved in journalism for so long
can have such an amateurish approach
to
um cross-examination
but um there were some benefits that
came from it and the purpose of this
particular video is to go through some
of the discussions that took place
um which I found interesting not least
because actually some mention of Muslim
men and Islam and the Quran itself was
made in the video
I would say that the video was pretty
much
um cut down into three different
segments the first segment
they were talking about Authority
and Piers Morgan's position is that if
one says
that a man has or should have maybe some
level of authority over a woman
in a husband-wife relationship that this
is tantamount in his eyes to misogyny
to which I think uh Tay argued
impressively
though not impressively enough in my
opinion that actually there are
circumstances where in which a man is
expected to put forward Services of
protection
and if that is the case
and a man if he were to protect the
woman could put himself or his life in
danger then why he why shouldn't he be
uh if you like in charge of the decision
making uh regarding that particular
woman in these contexts and potentially
other contexts as well
um Piers Morgan seemed not to be able to
differentiate between two different
types of authority
uh what is referred to as moral
Authority and what is also referred to
as legal Authority
he keep he kept attempting to
conflate the two categories and in logic
this is all informal logic this is
referred to as a category mistake
fallacy this actually referred to as a
category mistake fallacy so both of them
were using the same words
but both of them were using it in
completely different ways
and when Tate was explaining to him what
he meant by the word Authority which is
a moral Authority
Piers Morgan didn't seem to actually
comprehend this point which is totally
embarrassing for someone of his age and
someone who's been in the industry as
long as him someone who we would assume
to be an educated man
secondly I think there's more to be said
in fact there can be consequences legal
consequences when I say legal here we're
speaking in the British context but we
might as well be speaking in any Western
context
that can be imposed on let's say a wife
if
obedience is inhibited or obscured
for example
if a woman is not fulfilling her sexual
rights in the I'm giving you an Islamic
paradigm from the Islamic Paradigm if
the woman doesn't fulfill her sexual
rights and she leaves a man
she withholds from the man sexually
the man is within his right not to
provide for that woman
and this is actually mentioned the books
of jurisprudence so in other words if
she is receiving a monthly stipend or if
she is getting money
from the man
that he doesn't need to provide that for
her anymore because
she has decided to withhold so he can
also decide to withhold
now this is legal because there's
nothing in the law that says that a man
has to give a woman money
there's nothing in the law at all this
doesn't include of course the children
the children are separate
uh unit of analysis
but what I am saying is that there are
consequences
so even from a legal Paradigm Authority
can be manifest from a man to a woman
um in ways which are monetary now one
can argue what about the woman is
working already
well in the Islamic Paradigm even if the
woman is working the man should be
spending for the woman in the household
and so she would still be losing her
monetarily for them so Authority can be
manifest
the example that Tate gave about you
know locking her in the room and so on
this is something which we don't believe
in anyway as Muslims
so that's the first thing I will say the
second conversation they had and I think
here
Tate should be a little bit more
introspective and self-reflective
is where he referred to women as
property
and then he actually invoked the Quran
and the Bible
and said that this is mentioned the
Quran you can go back to the Quran and
paraphrasing or go back to the Bible or
something like this
well is this is actually a
misrepresentation
especially of the Quran there is nothing
like that in the Quran at all
and giving the example of a woman taking
us the second name of the man
that's not actually an Islamic principle
for example and since Islam came into
the picture it's important that this
clarification is made a woman keeps her
own name on the Islamic Paradigm why
because Islam came to protect five
things and five things and lineage is
one of them and that is for men and for
women
so I thought I thought that that
particular segment uh wasn't well
presented and I think he should take
responsibility for that
and considering the facts and I think
Morgan should have mentioned this that
his his business interests takes
business interests has been providing
um you know I don't know what it is
website Services sexual Services
webcam sexual services and stuff like
that
uh the the idea of mentioning women as
property I think is person to be honest
with you I think it is objectifying and
it is problematic and I think his
invocation of religion is problematic as
well he has no right to mention the
Quran he has no right to mention the
Bible in these things
uh thirdly I think um so that that's
really the two main segments then there
was a discussion about depression
uh I think that appears in a very poor
job there as well
um he could have once again he could
have done it you know asked some more
pressing questions
but what I will say is that to be honest
this Aura of invincibility that Andrew
Tate wants to
to manifest in the public sphere now
that is the the mask the faux mask of
invincibility uh is is clearly starting
to drop and to be honest with you I
don't even know why Tate went and spoke
to Piers Morgan in the first place his
agenda is very clear his tactics are
very well known
um he actually is known to distort
information before he puts it on public
he never he never wants a structure
which is a balanced in other words where
he himself is being interrogated as well
as being the interrogator he he has
never engaged in a public debate
he would prefer this to be the
interrogator and so this individual
um going on to his program I think was a
mistake especially considering the fact
that you know usually take where's his
sunglasses and the fact that you know
the the light was bouncing off his eyes
it seemed like it was a little bit
teary-eyed it seemed like it was a
little bit disheveled at times there was
no need for it at all
ah
in Islam there is a saying which is
the prophetic saying is that the upper
hand is better than the lower hand in
other words don't put yourself in a
position where you know
that the odds are against you you're
putting yourself in a disadvantageous
position by letting a man who is known
for his
incessant interrogation not allowing you
to finish Distortion of material to
speak to you the way he did with no
respect at all
and I think it shows some weakness and
tight because there were questions that
he asked which I was shocked at the the
response that Tate provided when he
asked for example are you a feminist
why couldn't you just offer him a
response and say no
we saw a new kind of
apologetic side of you which is
completely off-brand something which we
don't expect number one number two
you actually declared I think for the I
don't know I haven't been watching your
videos but you declare that you're a
libertarian
and your whole from what I understand
your whole thing
is about coming outside of the Matrix
now mentioning libertarian
that you're a Libertarian which you know
was
predicated on the liberal ethic liberal
you know political liberalism or
philosophical philosophical liberalism
to mention that you're a Libertarian
you're telling us that you're well
within the Matrix here
so what I will say to Tate is that
the way to really come out of the Matrix
as it were is not to be a Libertarian in
fact that's the dominant ethic that's
exactly what everyone wants us to be
but it's to be
the religion which I think you know is
true deep down
which is a Muslim to believe in one God
and to Worship in one God
to
to do God's work and what I mean by that
is to follow God's laws his legislation
and so on
uh and and to follow the Prophet
Muhammad
because you know what it is and I'll say
this and it'll be the last thing I say
it's really interesting
that the prophet Muhammad he went
through what he went through in life
people don't know that all of his
children
save one child which is Fatima died in
his own time
he was the person his wife died he went
through heartbreak after heartbreak and
uh you know his uncles died his closest
the closest people to him died
uh he went through Wars over 20 Wars he
participated in himself he had nine
wives at one time he was running a state
doing wars managing nine wives at one
time all of these things are incredible
things about a prophet Muhammad the
final prophet and it's itself I would
say is an evidence for his prophethood
following a man like that okay
who in the most difficult times is able
to persevere is able to to direct people
to be a the best leader you know who
we're mentioning a thousand four hundred
years after his death which will is way
more than we're going to say about any
of us okay
that's
that is true
uh religion okay that is the true
religion and that is a true
you will really succeed from from doing
these things
so that's all I have to say about that
and um hopefully we'll see each other
soon and assalamu alaikum